your first hint that you may be in the
presence of a kraken is that you catch
lots of fish and I mean a lot of fish
the Kraken is scaring the fish towards
the surface
and that's a harbinger of death for
unwary sailors
giant squids hunt by keeping still in
deep Waters when a fish gets close
enough to the dangling tentacles it's
pulled into the Squid's grasp and is
unable to escape the suction cups that
line the tentacles
we can assume that the Kraken hunts in a
similar style but fish isn't on its menu
it wants you your crew and your ship
it's also said that the Kraken was able
to pull massive ships completely
underwater with its tentacles